[Musique]
cette aventure européenne c'est en fait
celle d'un club qui depuis 2004 a choisi
l'équilibre avec ses deux sections
masculines et féminines l'Olympique
Lyonnais tient donc désormais sur deux
jambes de quoi imposer sa statue et
jouir un rôle moteur pour les filles des
autres clubs français
c'est vrai qu'on a fait ce qu'il fallait
pour leur donner une chance de devenir
un peu comme comme les garçons c'est à
dire de vrais stars d'avoir une vraie
équipe un vrai engouement avec le public
et puis surtout d'avoir un projet un
projet c'était de venir la meilleure
équipe de France mais surtout de devenir
la meilleure équipe d'Europe et donc
voilà donc c'est pas toujours facile
parce que le football français pour le
moment est pas très organisé autour du
football féminin donc il a fallu
effectivement donner un peu de soi-même
mais il y a un tel une telle passion une
telle spontanéité qu'on trouve moins
chez les garçons
partis le professionnalisme est passé
depuis plus longtemps que on est
largement rétribué de tout ce qu'on a
fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]